and thanksgiving is a day all about
friends family and traditions in here to
talk about that and teach us some new
traditions that we can adopt is the
wonder woman of cheese and valley cheese
and wine owner diana breyer welcome back
thanks for having me again oh we are so
excited because we're going to talk
about one of your family traditions yes
and you are going to educate us on
port wine tell us
how is this a tradition for you so it's
kind of newer in my family generally
speaking when you're thinking about
things that are you know special
occasion situations a lot of people
think champagne and not enough people
think about port port is an
exceptionally characteristic wine
blended of a
variety of grapes from the duro valley
of portugal and it usually shows such
vibrant flavor profiles and has a little
bit of alcohol added we call this a
fortified wine so it has a little bit of
alcohol added so it's a little bit more
on the palate has a little bit more of
like a supple characteristic on the
palette and really is just delicious so
what's the difference between port wine
and just regular wine though more
alcohol actually yeah so there's a few
differences port wine is blended and
aged for a long period of time sometimes
10 20 years
and then also port wine has alcohol
added during the fermentation process to
actually stop fermentation
create a higher abv and like make sure
that those distinguished flavor profiles
are very characteristic okay so you use
this in your your traditions tell us how
you do it so we always do port with
dessert but you can do port anytime
there's always a good time for port so
we actually started with a white port
and i wanted to have you taste this on
its own not a lot of people know about
white fort
and it is beautiful it has nutty
honey-like characteristics on the
palette this one is from broadbent so
this is from the duro valley in portugal
that's nice it's gonna remind you of
just like a little bit of like a honey
drop but in just the most beautiful like
classy way it's sweet but it's light at
the same time i really like that that's
beautiful who have had port before don't
actually care for it because of it being
a little bit sweeter yeah so white ports
are a really good way to sort of
contrast that because it lightens up the
flavor profile a little bit okay and
even if you don't like pork you can make
pork cocktails with white pork
especially so we made a ginger beer and
rosemary white pork cocktail and there's
there's a little spring in there i love
it
and this is going to be so approachable
for people who are your moscow mule
drinkers um it's got a beautiful it
actually smells like being cozy oh that
just tastes like the holidays it doesn't
mean it's very like spice it's very
autumnal it's perfect for the season
this is delicious with this yeah i
absolutely could see starting off the
meal with something like this now we
have one minute left so i want to get to
the red port too and you're pairing this
with a cheese so tawny port has a little
bit more of like maple characteristics
to it aged in oak barrels for 10 years
so this has a huge like robust flavor
profile and the thing that always goes
with port as a classic pairing is blue
cheese a lot of people are kind of
intimidated by blue cheese or they think
it's a little you know flavorful i love
blue cheese so i'm totally fine with it
is made with 100 sheep's milk um so it's
going to be a little bit more buttery
okay it has a little natural sweetness
to it go ahead and pick up a little
crumble there and try it with the tawny
pork and you'll notice that you actually
the butteriness of the sheep's milk
mixed with the tawny port is going to
give you a little bit of like a like a
maple like pancake okay i trust you on
this so what do i do put the cheese keep
it in my mouth okay chew it a couple
times and then chase it with pork
[Laughter]
that okay is good yeah it is a beautiful
beautiful representation of sheep's milk
cheese from france and it's like the
king of blue jesus oh my gosh
i thought you outdid yourself with our
previous pairing of the cheese with a
peanut butter cup how do you figure this
out this is why she is the wonder woman
of cheese oh this is fantastic how do
people come and visit you so i am valley
cheese and wine on horizon ridge in
henderson so we are at 1570 west horizon
ridge easiest way to remember between
valle verdi and stephanie and in
henderson um so we're happy to have you
any time
she's a genius she's a true genius
people this is fantastic you've got to
check it out thank you for educating us
thank you